madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur général de
la commission des affaires sociales
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
arrivons aujourd'hui au terme de
l'examen de ce PLFSS et en dépit de
certaines affirmations je considère que
le gouvernement a su au cours de
l'examen parlementaire écoutez et
intégrer à ce texte des propositions
constructives ayant permis de l'enrichir
et de l'améliorer je tiens ainsi à vous
remercier pour l'important travail
effectué
laissez-moi un instant revenir sur les
chiffres
5,2 %, c'est pour 2023 l'augmentation
inédite de l'objectif global de dépenses
pour le secteur médico-social il
atteindra ainsi 30 milliards d'euros
soit près de 1 milliard 5 de financement
supplémentaires
cette hausse des moyens bénéficie en
particulier
au personnel du secteur médico-social
auquel je tiens à rendre hommage et que
je remercie pour son engagement auprès
des personnes vulnérables
prise en compte de l'inflation
revalorisation salariale soutien de
l'accueil à domicile
recrutement de soignants voilà ce que le
PLFSS finance
de plus les tas su écouter les besoins
des territoires
près de 200 29 millions d'euros
supplémentaires ont été alloués à la
Caisse nationale de solidarité pour
l'autonomie pour compenser une partie
d'écoute de revalorisation salariale des
aides à domicile assumées par les
départements je parlais d'enrichissement
du texte lors de la navette
parlementaire en voici quelques exemples
report des heures non consommées de Lapa
indexation sur l'inflation du plancher
tarif du tarif planché pardon national
par heure d'intervention des services
prestations d'aide à domicile
suppression de la condition d'un recours
minimal à 16 heures de mode d'accueil
par mois pour bénéficier du complément
de mode de garde d'enfant
je profite de ce moment pour parler un
peu plus longuement des mesures en
faveur du handicap
là aussi ce PLFSS se caractérise par une
augmentation inédite des crédits
ce sont 730 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour poursuivre les
engagements pris lors de la dernière
conférence nationale du handicap de 2020
ainsi nous amplifions la mise en oeuvre
de grands objectifs et de politiques
prioritaires nous croyons en l'école
pour tous et ce budget contribue à
l'amélioration de la scolarisation des
enfants et adolescents en situation de
handicap avec notamment le déploiement
des unités d'enseignement autiste à
l'école maternelle et élémentaire et
l'approfondissement des coopérations
opérationnelles entre l'école et le
secteur médico-social ce budget finance
également des mesures ciblées en
direction des publics prioritaires
personne polyhandicapées personne
handicapées vieillissante politique du
handicap à l'Outre-mer prévention des
départs en Belgique autant d'axes sur
lesquels nous devons rattraper un retard
dernier grand bloc des actions financées
par ce PLFSS c'est la poursuite des
mesures concernant l'autisme et les
troubles du neurodéveloppement nous
étendons au 7-12 ans la politique de
détection précoce qui a permis après de
30 000 enfants depuis 3 ans d'être
détecté à temps et donc correctement
accompagné voici donc un PLFSS
résolument ambitieux pour le secteur du
handicap qui ont tant appuyé la
dynamique des progrès accomplis depuis
la dernière conférence nationale du
handicap par une hausse des moyens d'une
ampleur inédite
et un peu les fesses qui prépare le
terrain pour faire de la prochaine
Conférence nationale du handicap un vrai
tremplin pour la suite de notre action
car nous sommes en effet à quelques mois
de la prochaine Conférence nationale du
handicap que nous préparons activement
elle sera l'occasion de proposer un
changement de paradigme à la hauteur des
attentes des personnes en situation de
handicap sous l'égide de la première
ministre quatre grands axes ont été
fixés l'acte 2 de l'école et de
l'université inclusive la mobilisation
pour le plein emploi des personnes en
situation de handicap la simplification
des parcours des personnes et de l'offre
médico-sociale et l'accessibilité
universelle ces politiques nous
continuerons à les construire en
concertation étroite avec l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés je pense bien
évidemment au Comité national
consultatif des personnes handicapées
mais également aux élus locaux et en
particulier les départements et bien
entendu nous y associons la
représentation nationale car je sais que
vous de nombreux à vous investir sur le
sujet
ces perspectives d'avenir que nous
traçons ensemble elle se matérialise
également pour la politique du grand âge
avec le CNR bien vieillir sur tous les
territoires et pour la branche famille à
travers les consultations aux cours
autour du service public de la petite
enfance
ainsi mesdames messieurs les députés ce
PLF est un premier jalon de la politique
ambitieuse de solidarité que le
gouvernement ont emmené et peuvent le
chemin pour répondre aux attentes
légitimes de nos concitoyens
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]